let's talk about what's going on with
these uh with chicago man this story is
uh it's getting a little crazy we kind
of derailed a little bit there but uh
but here we go
from nbc chicago some suburban
departments won't send officers to
chicago if needed amid vaccine battle so
we have what is i think it's five
5833 in chicago officers out of
something like 12
600 who are either not getting
vaccinated or refusing to disclose or in
complete defiance they may get axed
and lori lifeless like well we don't
need them anyway because we'll find a
way yeah they find a way by calling
suburbs and saying please send us your
cops when they're having trouble now the
suburban department some of them are
like
on your own so this is a good indication
to um
get out of chicago get out of cities
yeah i gotta say it's gonna be bad in
chicago i mean what are you getting away
from like it's already horrible more
children died in chicago from gang
violence than than covid so so that that
should tell you something and uh it's
already a lawless place already most of
the murders there go unsolved so less
police officers i mean
they're just getting what they're voting
for so you're seeing this by the way the
same movement now with uh in buckhead
which is the large and very prosperous
uh precinct or district of atlanta where
they're saying they're suing essentially
to divorce themselves from the city and
i went on jesse kelly the other day and
he's a big proponent of national divorce
he says this is what we need can happen
i said we're not going to get a national
divorce jesse but we might get something
more along the lines of national
separation right it's like we're you
know we're living in the same house but
you know we're we're sleeping in
different bedrooms we're dating other
people you know but we're staying
together for the sake of the normies and
i think you're going to see that more
and more because if you look at illinois
as a state right it's it's like a bright
red state with the exception of chicago
right you know being it's just dark
blue right
yeah and it's the same with a
large majority of these states um
western maryland by the way has you know
kind of a secession movement where they
want to join up with west virginia
you're seeing this in a lot of different
states western maryland in western
maryland really there's a part of that
we're in western maryland right now we
are yes we are i like this because it's
actually off the lookout that's actually
something that people are talking about
so the idea of breaking away and then
joining other states that are maybe more
conducive to your views uh parts of
virginia are talking about this as well
yeah west virginia i think agreed to
accept or they they said they would
accept the virginia counties if they do
because the problem with virginia is
that it's essentially been annexed
through the blue suburbs of washington
dc and because they're so populated it
just you know the vote-wise it just
crouches and of course you've seen the
election you know it really is the
funniest thing in the world because uh
where we are right now i think you're
gonna see it i think we will see stuff
like that we are about from this house a
minute to virginia and west virginia
right no joke literally a minute so
we're just talking about it now that's
loud counting that's louder than county
right and i think it's funny when we
drive into virginia for you know
groceries or food and you see gadsden
flags everywhere and i'm like in this
state
no way dude deep blue democrat super
majority gadsden flags
yeah i can't believe people stayed in
virginia because i go and i i'll go to
some of these farms and talk to people
and they're like
not
these people understand what's happening
and i'm like why are you in virginia
you know you could literally just move a
block away and freedom this is just they
just don't move because it's too much of
a hassle well i don't think people care
that gets into i think that gets into
there's still a very genteel
um aristocratic kind of sense with a lot
of virginians a lot of the families that
have been there for a long time like
like we are virginians we are going to
stay in virginia this is what we do this
is who we are we would never leave
right you know regardless of what
happens you know the south should rise
again
you know is it isn't the gadsden flag
like a symbol of virginia like a state
flag or something well no no the safe
flag of virginia is except for taranis
it's right right on the flag um and i
say that as a pennsylvanian but um the
gazan flag is that's more of like a 1776
revolutionary flag right right
yeah but but you can get as your license
plate in virginia i'm pretty sure you
can yes
i was just looking at the state flag of
virginia it's like a roman dude standing
on top of another guy with a crown on
the ground wild yeah epic so what's six
semper tyrannus what does that mean unto
tyrants yes basically like the overthrow
of the tyrant it's it's what jonathan
when he assassinated abraham lincoln
but he wasn't no he wasn't the
originator of that of that phrase but
supposedly it's related to julius caesar
yeah yeah yeah and brutus roman tyranny
mm-hmm brutus
at two
i think we're also seeing a big
population shift i think we're seeing a
lot of people who
were right-wingers leave places like new
york city leave places like chicago
leave places like los angeles because
it's just becoming more and more
restrictive to to live there that's why
i think this kind of argument about the
national divorce is starting up because
the lines are being drawn very seriously
where people who don't believe in the
orthodoxy don't believe the narrative
can't live in new york city uh new york
city just by the way uh publicly
declared racism uh a
health emergency god bless you and they
finally
on their vaccine mandates getting rid of
testing uh as a requirement for
new york city employees yeah as an
alternative there's so many black
markets in new york city we have friends
that we have friends of the show they
come on periodically and they're they
live in new york and i'm like you're
crazy there's so many black market vax
cards going around
exactly
that's the big that's the hottest
industry in new york city right now a
postcard he's got to be willing to break
the law to make it which the fbi said
that they're going after and cracking
down on people oh they're probably
saying that they're going to uh be
implementing felonies for people who
fake right
but but yeah but they also accept
foreign fax cards yeah there's no
jurisdiction for so i guess what they've
said is that if you use a fake vex card
in any capacity it's fraud right but i
don't know if that actually constitutes
fraud it's it's a
i guess you'd be violating a civil uh
well there's no law it's a decree and
the plan the penalties on the business
not the person entering the business
and how would they know if a foreign vax
card is real or not unless they've been
to like you know i don't know the
maldives where they issued it or
something well they don't a lot of this
is just made up a lot of businesses are
not complying with it a lot of
businesses aren't even doing it like we
saw with the san francisco story with in
and out but new york city really getting
rid of testing for people who don't want
to be vaccinated and are city employees
there's over 300 thousand of them well
that is it's so ridiculous because it's
it's so anti-science it's so counter
their own narrative because people who
do get the vaccine according to the cdc
can get sick and can transmit the virus
but new york city is just limiting i
don't i just keep i don't want to keep
having an argument about testing because
the real issue is we shouldn't be
mandating people show their papers
nothing yeah of course so there's a
tendency among people to fall into the
left's framing every single time
so they'll be like vaccine mandates and
then everyone starts saying yeah but
what about natural immunity and they go
oh i guess you're right okay mandates
with some exceptions no no mandates i
didn't need my id or a vax card to go
shopping before and i don't think we
should do that now you want to talk
about kids going to public schools we'll
have a conversation about the the
research and the legislation for that no
mandates i don't care what they are what
they're for absolutely agree um but i
think it's also important to counter
their narratives because it's just so
ridiculous and so nonsensical and sadly
there's still some people in the middle
that that are so confused with with the
fear-mongering with the constant
flip-flopping that they don't know what
to make their minds about so i think
clarifying a lot of this nonsense to
them is important
the cops are even in new york you've got
cops that are pissed off you've got fdny
pissed off they're saying you're
violating our union contracts and if
you're in chicago oh you probably
already know how bad the crime can be
now imagine it getting worse suburbs
saying we're not going to help you this
is your problem
you've got cops in seattle walking off
the job turning in their boots turning
in their boots and we quit good for them
yeah people saying no continue so this
is why i say this folks enjoy your
leadership get out of cities for at
least i don't know the next five years
maybe more just the this is a downward
spiral this is something that i i hear
that schellenberger talked a little bit
about this but didn't talk about some of
the money that um you know that's being
put up behind these people like
chesaputian and larry krasner a lot of
this is soros money uh huge left-wing
institutional money that's going to
support these guys who let's just call
it what it is they're pro-crime they're
allowing crime to be committed in these
cities uh in philadelphia they're
stopping traffic stops just traffic
stops are now not going to be done in
the city of philadelphia yeah because
they claim it's racist new york city you
could shoot up with drugs and the cops
can't do anything yeah so they have this
area in philadelphia called kensington
and it's they call it the kensington
beach because it's essentially an open
air drug market where you can go and so
many people are doing drugs there
they're shooting up in public and then
kind of like passed out on the ground it
looks like they're you know guys hunting
themselves at the beach they call it
kensington beach and there's a few
there's a few like instagram accounts
and youtubes where you can go and just
see the absolute depravity and dregs of
human society i saw one video it was um
a woman with a newborn baby and still
had the umbilical cord on and she was
just lying there on the ground
wow
gosh that's that's your cities right now
in the united states so and it's only
going to get that much worse it's
getting worse i know it feels like
things are bad
this is just the beginning to get worse
people don't get it either man they
really don't like the washington post
they're like maybe instead of being
upset about they're not being food on
the shelves lower your expectations see
that no no there's a back story to that
to that op-ed so that op-ed i've been
told was planted by kamala harris's
press team
because yes yes
to to generate hatred for herself no
generate hatred towards joe biden oh
so to make his head blow up to make ron
clean and jill biden so this has been my
whole theory of the case and i've been
reporting this uh you know for months
now
we just had the leaked audio from the
white house from my insider my
whistleblower came out on this with the
vaccine mandates that what what one of
the big friction points between the two
sides we know kamala harris and joe
biden they were never friends right it
was a shotgun marriage you know he
wanted klobuchar originally but then
when blackmail's matter took off
you know
when that took off they the party
basically said you need to choose kamala
harris so they've been doing everything
they can because they can see and even
rasmussen had the story today
54 percent of voters now believe that
biden is in cognitive decline oh yeah
and
and that everyone kind of knows that
kamala harris is the freight train
that's coming forward so jensaki ron
klein and jill biden are doing
everything they can to say you know
throw sand on the tracks and you know
delay the inevitable oh we're going to
give her immigration oh we're going to
give her climate change oh we're going
to give her the border we're going to
give her all this stuff it doesn't
matter because no matter what you try to
do to sag her down
you're not going to help jeffy now think
about this
i want you to imagine something
in in this reality joe biden is a
fumbling bumbling idiot
he's screwing everything up he's our
yoke and kamala is coming for him
because this is her chance but now i
want to rewind and present to an
alternate theory an alternate reality
where they all
uh
obama and biden and hillary and the
democratic establishment sit down and
they say this is going to be rough for
us if we win in 2020 we're going to have
to reverse donald trump's policies
because they helped too many poor people
and we need this country to be torn and
gutted
but people will get mad at us so what do
we do so joe biden says look i'm old
give me one term to reverse trump's
policies and destroy this country and
then i'll take the heat for it and then
what does obama say you don't have to do
this joe remember that quote yes that's
what he really meant
joe was being a hero to the democrats
taking the fall and kamala right now as
the as the washington post was like
madam vice president uh democratic party
we'll do whatever you say do you want me
to press post right now and then
kamalaires is like
do it
and then they press enter and the tier
rolls down and then joe joe walks up to
her and puts his hand and shoulder says
it's okay
it needs to be this way she's like but
they'll never know what you did for this
country almost like no i can be that
hero yeah no i don't see it i i think i
think kama harris she
think of it she goes from a staffer to
the mayor of san francisco
to becoming the d.a of san francisco to
becoming the attorney general of
california to becoming the senator of
california
to becoming the vice president and she
will be ladies and gentlemen embrace it
embrace it she will be
the first female president of the united
states selected not elected but but what
i've also been told on this
she wants to pick another woman to be
the vice president i hope she picks
pelosi so you'll have a full
female actually i've heard um uh whitner
is the one that she's looking for
all females
because look look when we say that we
all start vomiting like in our mouths a
little bit they're saying the same thing
about trump
they're like trump's gonna run and it's
going to be trump again he is going to
right it's civil war dude
if you have a kamala harris trump ticket
it's just like
versus trump right right yeah no sorry
not together yeah no no
yeah kamala whitmore ticket i mean
that's just
that's it
wow yeah think about that so that i mean
that's that's right that's riley you got
to be ahead maybe trump just wins in a
landslide at that point i mean if you
look at the polls right now even like
quinnipiac and some of like the more
left lane quinnipiacs died in the wool
blue pole and they're basically saying
that trump would win if you ran today
so they're going to use as an excuse and
be like biden can't do it biden's going
to be like you know i did my best
and uh
the economy is better than whatever it
would probably be like um it'll probably
be like you know
oh there's a there's a heart issue or
there's something you're not gonna
actually see the 25th amendment but
behind the scenes it'll be like joe i
know that you failed the cognitive test
right i know that you couldn't draw the
clock i know that you couldn't say you
know purple monkey dishwasher
and
so you know either you resign or i'm
going to go through this thing and
destroy your legacy i just thought of a
really good idea for a meme because i've
been watching house
you know i'd love to see just like
someone put biden's face over the
patient when he's like true not a shot
with a pressure
and then you have house trying to
diagnose house yeah he's like yeah it's
like
you could rotoscope it yeah yeah yeah
you could be like you know the patient
has ticks
stumbling and falling down the stairs
you know failing to speak properly and
then during speech what is the diagnosis
and then the next t and then the next
scene is the team when they always have
that team scene where they're like like
could it be is it
sarcoidosis autoimmune is it autoimmune
it's it's never wait then who's house
though is it it's just houses it's just
him yeah but then you can have like
trump in there i guess and then it's
and then trump comes in he's just like
he's falling apart he's not doing very
well he's not doing you guys see this um
this breaking trump news by the way he's
he's announced he's launching a social
media network he saw this yep
he's a little too late i would say yeah
a little late to the show oh wait no
hold on a second i've got breaking news
my mom just texted me she says take off
your jacket people are saying your
t-shirt says ip usa no it's just i said
usa all right mom for you yeah i'm gonna
do it she's down in florida right now
let's talk about let's talk about
you